the jerogan experience
yes i mean it also goes back to the um
to the enlightenment to the idea that
god doesn't exist and the idea that the
human being is
is the measure of all things well if the
human being is the measure of all things
what does that mean our reason and our
reason is completely flawed all of us do
things every day which are unreasonable
sinful wrong and absurd right and the
reasonable person says wait a second why
did i do that what do i have to refer to
in my confusion and my self-loathing
well the bible was a pretty good bet
you know for the hebrew bible for six
thousand years right the
christian bible for two thousands pretty
good bets say wait a second let's talk
about human nature you really aren't
that smart you really aren't in charge
of the world you really aren't although
you think you are you think that because
you're human
but god's in charge of the world and
there's a certain way things are and if
you'd like to get out of your wretched
self-consciousness and self-delusion you
better get your ass into church
but don't you think that you know when
atheists talk about
religion and they criticize uh
organized religion and criticize the
bible they they talk about things that
are in the bible that seem preposterous
right they talk about people rising from
the dead and walking on water
particularly the old testament right
like to use that as a guidebook for life
you have to kind of ignore some of the
stuff that doesn't make sense
well don't you think the bible's a myth
okay the bible especially the heb the
christian bible comes out of the the
jewish bible it's a it's a retelling of
the story in a different way but the
jewish bible is a myth and the myth is
the myth of creation and the myth of
human experience so what it does is
uh chapter by chapter story by story
it
challenges us with disturbing
and bizarre images and which says
why don't you try to understand this
see if you can understand this what does
it really mean to escape from egypt does
it mean escaping from your inner pharaoh
what does it really mean to part the red
sea so these these stories are told any
myth
is a
dramatic retelling of an underlying
reality that can't be expressed
rationally
right so the atheists say everything can
be expressed rationally for example you
know that the earth is burning up you
can tell that because sometimes things
get warmer and sometimes things get
colder you can also tell that when
things get colder that's obviously
because the earth is burning up because
the sun is melting the glaciers and the
glaciers are raising the temperature
you can also tell of course that to be
fair to everyone children change sex you
know that don't you and you can tell
that men can compete as women and women
compete as men this is all
human confusion because we trust
our senses and we trust our mind and the
mind just
it doesn't work real good we're very
cunning but we aren't very smart human
beings and that's the message of the
bible
and so if you look at
moses sorry moses moses was they tried
the egyptians tried to kill him all of
his life the egyptians tried to kill he
didn't have any trouble with the
egyptians
because god was on his side he had
trouble with the jews because the jews
were always saying who the hell do you
think you are
so that's that
all the old testament is the story of
atheists really saying who the hell do
you think you are
so
when when you're talking about the bible
right what i mean in the lessons in the
bible isn't part of the problem is that
your people translated it from ancient
hebrew to latin to greek and all these
other languages and eventually to
english like a lot's lost along the way
right and a lot is open to
interpretation like a lot of what we're
talking about in these myths and stories
that people take as
factual occurrences
they probably were
some sort of uh there's some sort of a
lesson in the myth some sort of allegory
there's there's there's things about
these stories that probably have hints
of truth but isn't it hard to kind of
decipher it all
if you can't speak the mother language
that's a very good question so i want to
first of all let me ask you okay i'm
going to tell you a story okay okay
these two octopuses walk into a a
laundromat okay see that's what a myth
is
i said two octopuses walk into a
laundromat and you didn't say wait a
second octopuses can't walk and they
wouldn't be in a long time i thought
about it but i'm being polite
so what you said is yeah tell me more
okay i'm hoping there's a good joke okay
well i'll get to that but it's the same
thing with the the bible is really two
octopuses walk into a laundromat so i'm
going to tell you a story i want you to
support suspend your disbelief because
there's something in this story you
might get a kick out of you might and
you might there might be some wisdom in
it there might yes and might know but if
you listen
as you would to a story which the bible
is it's a myth rather than to a factual
retelling you might get a kick out of it
now as far as a translation goes i can
read the bible in hebrew i learned
started learning when i was 40. it's
easy language and there are a lot of
mistranslations
uh but the the main point is not the
missed translations because there are
some pretty good english translations
too but the main point is thing that
doesn't make sense that doesn't make
sense so what do you think the bible is
do you think the bible is a bunch of
very wise people got together and they
form these stories to sort of
illustrate the folly of mankind and how
one needs to have like a moral compass
and guiding principles that are set in
stone and that you have
these rules to live your life in a moral
and just way and that'll make for a
better society like where do what do you
think the bible actually is well a
friend of mine a rabbi was a reformed
rabbi was applying to get into an
orthodox uh yeshiva an orthodox college
and he's a reformed rabbi so the guy
says he says you have very good
credentials and you're very well nerded
do you think
the bible is literally the work of god
the rabbi says no so the guy says well
is it possible
robert says yes guy says okay you're in
right so this dennis prager you know
who
i'm crazy about
said the other day he said you know i
don't believe
in the torah the jewish bible because of
god
he said i believe in god because of the
torah so if you read the torah of the
jewish bible and the christian bible is
just an extension of that you say my god
this is incredible wisdom this goes back
to the beginning of time people who have
tried to figure out everything and they
didn't have the language that we have
but they had the language that they had
and this was thousands of years of
experience progressed and compressed
into a myth so we know that this is true
because like liberals have always been
in love with the myths especially jews
with the myths of other cultures
right we say how beautiful it is that
this culture has that myth that the
hayden indians say the world was formed
by a large beaver and when the beaver
slapped his tail like that it made the
oceans and when the blah blah bless
that's gorgeous myth
nobody says of that myth wait a second
you can't have a beaver that big
right
that's what i would say yeah okay i
would step in and go hey man